non campé en plein coeur de paris ce
n'est pas la dernière tendance
touristique en ces temps troublés
ces jeunes se disent mineurs et sont
venus du mali de côte d'ivoire du
sénégal est d'ailleurs en quête d'un
idéal européen sont à la rue toujours à
vue toujours eu à gérer a beaucoup de
sujets pour moi j'ai là et a pas de
poignées et avoir d'autres auteurs
mamadou c'est un nom d'emprunt dit qu'il
a 16 ans qui aurait dû lui valoir une
protection une prise en charge immédiate
en france mais les autorités ne l'ont
pas cru mineur il arrivé ici tu avais
aucun papier pas d'acte de naissance par
une angine au moment des faits
le conseil départemental plus ou moins a
dit vous êtes majeur et à partir de là
ils sont dans un vide juridique
donc en fait ils n'ont accès à rien ni à
l'hébergement pour les adultes ni à
l'hébergement pour les enfants ya du
suivi éducatif rien c'est vraiment les
délais c'est laissé à la rue abandonné
un collectif de cinq associations dont
utopia 56 et médecins sans frontières a
voulu braquer les projecteurs sur la
situation de ces mineurs étrangers non
accompagnés en établissant le campement
et y en as rappelle en fait ils sont là
ils existent ils sont pas invisibles
maintenant on veut que tous les mineurs
en période de recours soit dans des
dispositifs de prise en charge de l'état
jusqu'à épuisement finalement de
l'endroit de leur recours comme ça
devrait être sur des bénévoles viennent
enseigner le français à une petite place
improvisé qui se concentrent du mieux
qu'elle peut dans le brouhaha de la
métropole
c'est bien loin de la bonne école dont
plusieurs rêver en amorçant le périlleux
voyage avec passage obligé par la libye
mohamed encore un nom d'emprunt raconté
avoir perdu le contact avec son grand
frère s'est lui dit tim qui avait tout
organisé avant qu'il ne quitte la côte
d'ivoire nouvelle vie il fut pas et sait
pas il vivait le mot je sais pas où en
prison à son arrivée il a d'abord été
reconnu comme une armée à cause d'une
apparente négligence administrative
on a perdu son droit d'hébergement il a
connu la violence et les abus sur la
route sont arrivés en france il me
semble tout aussi bolton est arrivé ici
c'est peut être à peu près les mêmes
mais ici les premiers concurrents ne
fera pas c'est ça le problème
mais on te blesse un peu un peu pour
gâcher ta vie nous fait pour que titi
fini de larry tu deviens fou les gens
vont te régaler tout au long du voyage
plein et noah qui sont plus la ville de
paris ne compte pas expulser la centaine
de jeunes en attente d'une audition
devant le juge des enfants pour en
appeler de la décision administrative
sur leur statut de mineur et dit avoir
demandé à la préfecture de trouver un
endroit approprié pour les héberger
convenablement
en attendant d'autres jeunes avec tous
les jours là de jeunes qui sont notifiés
de leur majorité
tous les jours actuellement dix quinze
vingt jeunes et du coup qui commencent
leurs recours et qui viennent nous voir
en disant nous aussi on aimerait bien
être là parce que sinon on est dans la
rue seuls et on se fait voler nos
affaires et c'est pourquoi celui ci
allait se loger au fait si ce n'est pas
chez nous la fin nous parlons ici les
associations croyait que la stratégie
choc du camp a même un boulevard
parisien serait de courte durée mais le
temps passe et si ce n'est pas celle
dont il rêvait tous entre les match de
ping pong pour tromper l'ennui
une sorte de vie s'organise et prend
racine ici marie-eve bédard radio-canada
paris